noi siamo all'alba della civilizzazione
digitale
ce ne siamo accorti probabilmente perché
la posta diventata elettronica perché la
musica i film sono diventati liquidi
perché tutto ciò che una volta pesava
sui nostri scaffali pensiamo alle
ciclope di è scomparso sostituito da
wikipedia
bene oggi c'è l'aspettativa a torto oa
ragione che un intero sistema bancario
finanziario entri nei nostri smartphone
lo aveva già predetto peraltro un premio
nobel per l'economia come milton
friedman il quale nel 99 ha detto ciò
che manca e che sarà sicuramente
inventato a breve è una forma di
contante digitale ma date non di moneta
elettronica che associata degli
individui ma di contante al portatore
utilizzabile senza identificazioni da
tutti su internet
ecco quella profezia vede oggi la sua
realizzazione in b coin che è
assolutamente in pole position in questa
gara perché non tanto per il fatto di
essere evidentemente digitale anche i
nostri euro e dollari di fatto sono
ormai da tempo digitali quanto per
essere decentralizzato non accelera le
sue spalle è un'organizzazione un
governo che in qualche maniera né
coordino facciano da supervisori del suo
funzionamento
e questo anche se un po ci inquieta è in
realtà una garanzia molto forte sul
fatto che bitcoin non potrà mai essere
manipolato
si tratta di quella forma di innovazione
che gli anglosassoni chiamano permission
l'asean ovation
cosa si intende per un'innovazione che
non chiede permesso è un'innovazione che
non ha meccanismi di sicurezza
centralizzati che non a controlli
all'ingresso che non ha un sistema di
controllo editoriale dei contenuti
se vi sembra un piano un po troppo
anarchico e vi state spaventando non
fatelo è un'innovazione che avete già
visto all'opera e sa essere molto
efficace ma anche molto gentile
l'email ad esempio non è stato inventato
da un consorzio di uffici postali
internet non è stata inventata da un
consorzio di telecomunicazioni per quale
motivo
network transazionale del valore debba
essere inventato da un consorzio di
banche
beh lasciatemi dire che il sottoscritto
lo trova alquanto in plausibile
io ho scoperto bitcoin nel 2014 di
formazione sono un fisico e ho lavorato
per oltre 20 anni nel mondo delle banche
di investimento su finanza e derivati
bene io non mi ero mai posto la domanda
su cosa fosse la moneta
la prima volta in vita mia che me la
sono posta e quando scoperto bitcoin
questo è il più bel regalo che bisogna
abbia finora fatto e allora proverei con
voi giocosamente si intende a fare tutta
la storia della moneta
in tre minuti proviamoci la prima forma
di moneta che vediamo affermarsi nella
storia è loro perché l'oro ma vi
sembrerà strano ma per due
caratteristiche fondamentali perché
scarso e per che luccica
sì pare che a noi piacciono veramente
molto a noi esseri umani le cose che
luccicano loro è anche molto malleabile
e apprezzarne la purezza è relativamente
facile
prendete un paiolo accendete un fuoco
sotto fate fondere loro attendete che si
raffreddi se dopo questo violentissimo
ciclo termodinamico luccica ancora e oro
qualsiasi altra cosa vi garantisco
smette di luccicare se però per ogni
transazione commerciale
noi dovessimo accendere un paiolo
insomma è piuttosto faticoso
ecco che allora abbiamo chiesto a giulio
si giulio cesare
senti giulio perché non metti la tua
faccia sulla moneta d'oro in maniera da
garantirne il suo contenuto aureo la
prima crisi frazione della storia è già
sotto il successore di cesare sotto il
successore di giulio cesare cesar
augusto anche la plebe si rende conto
che nel sesterzio non c'è l'oro che
dovrebbe esserci ma se siete un mercante
medioevale loro anche un altro problema
pesa tantissimo ha una densità
elevatissime quindi scomodo da portare
dietro nonché piuttosto pericoloso
perché i briganti possono
derubarli e allora quasi
contemporaneamente nella storia gli
orefici londinesi e quelli che
diventeranno i banchieri italiani hanno
la stessa idea propongono ai mercanti di
lasciare loro presso i loro forzieri e
danno in cambio un certificato che prima
nominativo ma poi diventa al portatore è
una nota di banco con la quale presso il
loro banco pegni è possibile redimere
l'oro depositato nasce la banconota
moneta rappresentativa di valore
custodito altrove
entrambi però non resistono alla
tentazione perché fanno un osservazione
fondamentale notano che ben pochi
redimono la banconota in oro e quindi
hanno quella che potremmo definire un
alzata di genio
se mettiamo più banconote dell'oro che
abbiamo nei nostri forzieri che se ne
accorge e la risposta sapete qual è
nessuno nasce quindi la moneta
frazionaria ci sono più banconote
nell'oro che c'è a garanzia
andiamo veloci nella storia 1972
pur in un regime di moneta frazionaria
la redimibili ta aurea delle monete o
del dollaro statunitense nel caso che
stiamo analizzando resta un po una palla
al piede della discrezionalità di
politica monetaria
ecco che allora di cianni hickson decide
che no basta il dollaro statunitense non
è più convertibile in oro
da allora abbiamo fiat money proprio nel
senso di fiat lux et lux fuit moneta che
ha valore solo convenzionale solo perché
decidiamo che abbia valore da contratto
sociale e se qualcuno è d'accordo con
noi lo costringiamo attraverso una cosa
che si chiama corso legale rifiuta
abilità del fiat money dell'estinzione
di un debito
lasciatemi dire che questa moneta e una
cattiva moneta anzi potremmo anche dire
una pessima moneta senza andare a
guardare esempi assolutamente
macroscopici o deleteri della storia
della moneta
anche il buon vecchio caro dollaro
statunitense non ha proprio una
performance impeccabile pensate che dal
1913 l'anno di fondazione della fede
il dollaro statunitense ha perso oltre
il 96 per cento del suo potere di
acquisto e quindi una cattiva moneta
tipico risultato di una situazione di
monopolio friedrich von hayek premio
nobel per l'economia è il fondatore
della scuola austriaca del pensiero
economico scrive un intero trattato
lamentando il fatto che noi possiamo
considerare il monopolio governativo
della moneta come indispensabile noi che
non accetteremo il monopolio di nulla di
nessun bene in economia di mercato
accettiamo proprio il monopolio di quel
bene sintetico che entra al 50 per cento
di qualunque transazione commerciale
cioè la moneta come tutti i monopoli non
solo ci ha dato un cattivo prodotto ma
ci ha impedito di sperimentare alla
ricerca di prodotti migliori e allora
concluderà agli ex e mai vorremmo
rivedere una buona moneta dobbiamo
toglierla dalle mani degli stati
e siccome non possiamo farlo con la
violenza bontà sua
e io mi adeguo volentieri a questo
invito
dovremo farlo con un astuto stratagemma
qualcosa che non possano fermare di coin
è esattamente questo astuto tra
stratagemma ma proviamo ad approfondire
più intrinsecamente che cosa è la moneta
la moneta è fondamentalmente uno
strumento di relazione sociale
sì lo so che magari vi spiazza questa
definizione ma se voi pensate alla
vostra esperienza
noi tutti nasciamo nell'economia del
dono
spero per voi che nessuno di voi abbia
dovuto pagare per le cure parentali che
mamma e papà gli hanno fornito è
altrimenti veramente mi dispiace per voi
e sono lieto per il vostro analista che
sicuramente avrà da lavorare con voi ma
questa economia del dono non si allarga
solo alla famiglia agli amici ai vicini
diciamo così tra virgolette a tutta la
tribù è un'economia che però non scala
perché prima o poi incontriamo persone
di cui persone che non conosciamo e per
questo non ci fidiamo di loro a volte
talvolta non ci fidiamo di loro perché
le conosciamo ma è un po lo stesso
e allora noi che però siamo
intrinsecamente animali socievoli
siamo in
antropologicamente sociali
vogliamo cooperare anche con coloro di
cui non ci fidiamo e allora prima
abbiamo inventato il baratto
io do le mie uova lei ma sarà il caso
che io debba volere le sue il suo latte
oggi oppure per disintermediare nel
tempo e nello spazio il baratto
inventiamo la moneta un bene sintetico
per cooperare con coloro di cui non ci
fidiamo
non so voi ma io auspico un momento di
commozione intellettuale perché a me
questa osservazione sembra di una
portata gigantesca la moneta è lo
strumento per cooperare con i nostri
simili di cui non ci fidiamo
e allora evidente che oggi in economia
che per la prima volta un'economia
dell'informazione digitale e globale
viene la necessità di una moneta
sovranazionale di una moneta digitale ma
di una moneta non controllata da stati
di una moneta globale di una moneta di
internet e il problema che nel tentare
di fare una moneta di internet ci sono
delle difficoltà gigantesche la
difficoltà più grossa il cosiddetto
problema della doppia spesa
tutte le volte che noi abbiamo un
artefatto digitale che rappresenta
valore
abbiamo sempre avuto bisogno di
un'autorità centrale che ne impedisca la
duplicazione e se essendo digitale e
duplicabile non è difficile pensate al
saldo del vostro conto corrente
se io bonifica sia lei il saldo del mio
conto corrente non si faccia illusioni
frattaglie quando poi tentasse di
bonificarlo anche al signore la mia
banca che presiedo l'aggiornamento del
suo registro contabile mi direbbe no
ferdinando non puoi farlo come facciamo
a creare un asset digitale che abbia
valore cioè non sia duplicabile perché
pensate ad esempio alla gioconda
bellissima senza dubbio il suo prezzo di
mercato inestimabile ma se fosse
duplicabile arbitra elementi di un
numero limitato di copie perfette
resterebbe altrettanto bella ma il suo
valore di mercato con le reti a zero ed
ebi con riesce proprio in questo ed è
quindi limitato a 21 milioni di bitcoin
di coin da un certo punto di vista è
scarso come l'oro a livello fisico
bitcoin lo è a livello di
o perlomeno vuole essere l'equivalente
digitale dell'oro e quei ospite ray un
secondo momento di commozione
intellettuale perché tutto sommato sono
abbastanza sicuro che entrando in questo
teatro voi tutti siete entrati convinti
che qualsiasi cosa digitale può essere
duplicata vico invii smentisce proprio
su questo punto straordinario è un oro
digitale peraltro con annesso intrinseco
abitò il medesimo il network
transazionale incensurabile sicuro con
cui trasferire a livello globale
quest'oro lo so che siete scettici lo
vedono le facce allora facciamo un altro
gioco immaginiamo che arrivi un alieno
d'accordo e voi spiegate le monete
tradizionali e io spiego bitcoin allora
io parto subito e incomincio a dire
all'alieno guarda che le loro monete non
hanno alcun valore intrinseco e vuole
giustamente un po piccato ribatte tesi
ma ferdinando anche il tuo bitcoin è un
alcun valore intrinseco e io ma come vi
ho appena spiegato la scarsità in ambito
digitale ma avete giorno facili sì però
vuoi mettere il contratto sociale secoli
su questa storia della moneta il corso
legale va bene uno pari palla al centro
ripartiamo
ripartiamo io però a questo punto
incomincio a prendervi in giro che il
contante che vi portate in giro sono
foglietti colorati e si va bene carta
speciale inchiostro speciale ma signori
sono le banconote del monopoli è né più
né meno invece il mio contante e
matematica e crittografia
non solo ma poi faccio notare a questa
alieno che mentre io sono gentile il mio
bitcoin a voi non non lo forzo in alcun
modo
e voi siete abbastanza coercitivi il
vostro euro io non posso fare a meno di
usarlo
il corso legale dice che se un mio
creditore vuole saldare il mio se un
editore vuole saltare il suo debito con
me in euro io non posso rifiutarlo
lasciamo lascio a voi ricavare quale si
ha l'impressione che l'alieno si farà di
questa cosa ah ma dimenticavo
forse bisognerebbe dire all'alieno anche
che abbiamo un signore a francoforte 1
serissimo e per carità il più serio fra
di noi che di quei foglietti di carta
colorata po stamparne quanti ne vuoi
quando vuole darle a chi vuole non è
stato eletto e non dovrà rispondere a
nessuno di come interpreta il suo
mandato
io invece ho già spiegato l'alieno che
la politica monetaria di bitcoin è
perfettamente deterministica non
influenzabile da nessuno mi direte sì ma
sto piccoli non lo usa nessuno non si
vedono transazioni in b coin e ci credo
che ha comprato nel 2010 due pizze
pagando le diecimila bitcoin cioè il
corso attuale 40 milioni di dollari
beh speriamo che quelle pizze fossero
almeno molto ma molto buone perché io
non avrei non sarei riuscito a digerirle
in qualche modo di coin è un bene
rifugio quindi si tesaurizza e allora è
più opportuno confrontarlo non con la
moneta ma con loro fisico loro è stato
accettato da tutte le civilizzazioni
come prima forma di moneta senza alcuna
pianificazione centralizzata per secoli
è stata la forma di moneta di maggior
successo ha innescato lo sviluppo di
tutti i sistemi monetari che conosciamo
è stato superato da forme di moneta più
sofisticata senza per questo diventare
obsoleto bene quello che è successo nei
secoli al loro fisico sta succedendo in
questi dieci anni e probabilmente nei
prossimi decenni a bitcoin di bitcoin
spaventa moltissimo questa volatilità
sale scende
beh guardate che non c'è molto da
spaventarsi per carità tutte le volte
che si parla di bitcoin fate bene ad
allacciare le cinture di sicurezza i
percorsi sono sempre molto accidentati
ma questa volatilità è fisiologica
quando domanda e offerta sul mercato
tentano di mettere a fuoco il valore di
un bene se questo bene controverso come
loro digitale il processo sarà
altrettanto controverso abbiamo visto
nella storia a cadere anche per il
commercio elettronico andate a guardare
la storia della quotazione di amazon.com
e volatile di miccoli in quello che
spaventa però il cosiddetto drawdown
cioè il fatto che da massimo a minimo è
stato in grado di perdere ben oltre il
93 per cento del suo valore
quindi il messaggio da portare a casa e
che semmai voleste investire in bitcoin
vi prego fatelo con una piccola
percentuale dei vostri risparmi quella
quantità dei vostri risparmi di cui
potete ragionevolmente sostenere
la perdita integrale ma la buona notizia
è che miccoli non ha correlazione con le
altre asset class di investimento con le
altre opportunità di investimento non si
muove assieme a loro diversifica i
rischi quindi introdotto in un
portafoglio di investimento sembrerà
paradossale ma abbatte i rischi di quel
portafoglio a parità di rendimento
atteso o a parità di rischio aumenta
grandemente il rendimento atteso è
quindi ragionevole fare un piccolo
investimento in bitcoin ma questo ci da
uno spunto per qualche valutazione di
massima
immaginiamo che il 2 per cento dei
patrimoni gestiti banati non parlo del 2
per cento della ricchezza globale
mondiale ma il 2 per cento dei patrimoni
gestiti professionalmente investano nei
prossimi anni in bitcoin beh se facciamo
due conti un b coin deve andare a valere
100.000 dollari
se vi coin invece è o dimostrasse di
essere oro digitale e dico se perché
ricordiamo su un esperimento ardito
potrebbe fallire ma è un esperimento
culturalmente tecnologicamente
sostanziato ripeto se fosse ora digitale
beh signori è meglio del loro fisico
leggerissimo trasferibili
istantaneamente con costi transazionali
bassissimi senza problemi logistici in
maniera incensurabile è inarrestabile e
allora se bitcoin andasse a
capitalizzare quanto capitalizza oggi
l'oro al mondo un piccolo e dovrebbe
valere 400mila dollari 100 mila dollari
400 mila dollari
signori io non sono qui a vendere
bitcoin io sto soltanto dicendo che se
bitcoin eurodigital e allora oggi è
grandemente sottovalutato ma qualcuno mi
obietta no ma ho letto che non è il
bitcoin è la block chain la tecnologia
sottostante bitcoin a essere
fondamentale io amo
da questo punto di vista parafrasare
confucio il quale diceva quando un uomo
saggio indica la luna gli stolti
guardano il dito e la luna e di coin e
il dito la blow chain perché non può
sfuggirvi
la rilevanza del fenomeno bitcoin se
avete un minimo di consapevolezza di
quale sia stato il ruolo del loro fisico
nella storia della civilizzazione
della finanza e della moneta
l'emergere dell'equivalente digitale
dell'oro nella civilizzazione digitale e
nel futuro della finanza della moneta
sarà dirompente e allora io concluderei
con una osservazione 25 27 anni fa io
che usavo l'email e in generale navigavo
sul web
non avrei mai potuto immaginare che sul
protocollo tcp ip cioè sulla tecnologia
sottostante web ed email
avremo in futuro organizzato i nostri
weekend in dei club digitali facebook
piuttosto che comprato libri e dischi in
formato liquido sui negozi online o
ancora che avremmo fatto domanda in
lingua naturale ad un computer a un
assistente digitale aspettandoci delle
risposte sensate
ecco io non so dirvi tra vent'anni sul
tcp ip del valore che cosa avremmo quali
applicazioni incredibili ci potranno
essere questa è proprio l'avventura che
aspetta tutti noi oltre l'orizzonte
grazie
[Applauso]